bonsoir à tous
je m'appelle Grégoire j'aimerais vous
raconter une petite histoire celle de ma
relation avec le rugby un sport d'impact
d'impact tout d'abord pour la violence
des chocs qu'il peut y avoir sur un
terrain mais d'impact surtout pour tout
ce que ce sport peut apporter à
quelqu'un
je viens du Pays Basque et ça fait
maintenant 10 ans que je pratique le
rugby et tout a commencé lors d'un choix
que toute originaire du Pays Basque doit
faire un moment donné dans sa vie le
surf ou le rugby
alors reformuler un petit peu ça revient
choisir entre d'un côté être le beau
gosse sur la plage les cheveux longs au
soleil le cordonzé magnifique et de
l'autre côté passer ces samedis à
prendre des coups dans la gueule et à
manger de la boue
et je crois que j'avais pas encore
développé un esprit critique suffisant à
ce moment-là parce qu'elle est affronter
des golgots sur un terrain m'a paru
comme le choix le plus souhaitable avant
de commencer le rugby il faut vous dire
que j'étais très timide très introverti
je ne parlais pas beaucoup pour vous
donner un exemple j'ai pleuré à ma
rentrée en CP
ce n'est qu'un exemple parmi tant
d'autres exploits personnels mais pour
ma dignité personnelle je préfère
m'arrêter là
et physiquement c'était pas mieux
j'avais 14 ans je ressemblais à une
asperge je savais pas courir je savais
pas tenir un ballon dans les mains et je
crois que j'avais le casque le plus
moche qui puisse exister c'était le
combo parfait
voilà la photo
alors que maintenant comme vous pouvez
le voir
rien n'a changé rien n'a changé je suis
toujours le même
toujours le même tout du moins
physiquement parce que les plus grands
changements qui ont eu place se sont
passés à deux endroits ici et ici
et c'est le premier sujet que j'aimerais
aborder avec vous ce soir c'est le rugby
comme transformateur personnel
on dit souvent que le rugby c'est
l'école de la vie et je ne peux qu'être
d'accord avec cette phrase car le rugby
repose sur des valeurs humaines des
valeurs humaines que tout pratiquant
porte avec lui sur le terrain mais
également en dehors et ces valeurs sont
transmises par des encadrants et des
entraîneurs qui œuvrent de façon
bénévole pour construire des individus
sur des valeurs de la solidarité de
l'altruisme du courage et j'aimerais
remercier
tous ces encadrants tous ces entraîneurs
pour ce travail qui réalisent au
quotidien
ces valeurs ce sont la pierre angulaire
du rugby on y apprend le dépassement de
soi par les efforts intenses qu'ils
demandent et on apprend la solidarité
lorsqu'il faut aider le copain qui est à
côté et ce sont ces valeurs qui
permettent de créer un groupe de créer
une équipe soudée dans laquelle tout
individu peut trouver sa place et
s'épanouir pleinement
le rugby permet également de vivre des
émotions intenses qu'on ne retrouve que
sur un terrain et on parcourt tout le
spectre des émotions ça va de la joie à
la tristesse la concentration ou encore
parfois la colère
j'aimerais vous raconter un moment
d'émotion intense que j'ai vécu
récemment
je joue au club de la maison basque de
Paris cette année ou cette année l'année
dernière et l'année dernière nous avons
réussi à nous qualifier pour la finale
de notre championnat
et comme vous le savez une finale ça ne
se joue pas ça se gagne
sauf que cette fois on a perdu
et on avait ressenti une émotion intense
une tristesse folle juste après le match
mais pourtant paradoxalement
j'avais un sourire aux lèvres et je
ressentais une joie intense et je
n'étais pas le seul à ressentir cette
joie intense tous mes copains c'était
pareil
parce qu'au-delà d'une défaite nous
avons réussi à construire un groupe une
équipe soudée tout au long de l'année
une belle bande de potes donc maintenant
je fais partie et pour qui je serai prêt
à tout faire aujourd'hui
et une petite citation qui peut paraître
un peu bête à entendre la première fois
mais qui pour moi est pleine de sens
c'est le rugby c'est l'histoire d'un
ballon avec des copains autour
et lorsqu'il n'y a plus le ballon il
reste les copains
et pour moi c'est ça c'est ça le rugby
c'est ça c'est regroupé des hommes et
des femmes autour d'une passion mais
créer des relations qui vont dépasser le
cadre de ce sport
et c'est ce qui m'amène au deuxième
sujet que j'aimerais aborder avec vous
c'est le rugby comme connecteur social
le terrain c'est le l'endroit le lieu de
croisement entre des individus aux
origines et au profils très différents
mais qu'importe notre origine une fois
qu'on a le maillot sur le dos on est
tous les mêmes il n'y a qu'une seule
chose qui compte c'est ce qu'on fait sur
le terrain
le petit va côtoyer le grand le gros va
côtoyer le maigre le lent le rapide et
ce qui est génial avec ce sport c'est
que qu'importe notre physique on a
besoin de tous les profils pour faire
une équipe cohérente et on a beaucoup
courir le 100m plus rapidement que tout
le monde jamais on arrivera à gagner
tout seul
et c'est ce qui fait du rugby un
formidable intégrateur social
et j'ai vécu j'ai expérimenté ce fait
pendant toutes mes années de pratique et
en particulier pendant deux expériences
la première a eu lieu lorsque j'étais en
école d'ingénieur à l'insta Paris à
Palaiseau donc juste à côté
nous avions en partenariat avec le club
de Massy
nous donnions du soutien scolaire aux
étudiants aux jeunes des sports études
en échange de soutien logistique lors de
nos événements
et c'était génial de pouvoir vivre et de
pouvoir passer des moments avec des
jeunes qui ont le potentiel de pouvoir
vivre de leur passion de pouvoir devenir
professionnel on les voit au quotidien
s'arracher tout le temps tout le temps
sans jamais s'arrêter alterner entre les
cours les entraînements les matchs pour
atteindre leurs objectifs
malheureusement
le monde professionnel est très
compliqué d'accès
et seul une poignée d'entre eux
et alors qu'ils auraient pu se
considérer comme des rivaux au contraire
je crois que je n'ai jamais vu un groupe
aussi soudé que le leur
et c'était magnifique à voir il
s'entraider tout le temps il y en avait
jamais rien qui était laissé sur la
touche tout le monde avait droit à sa
chance et le programme de sport étude
demandait une moyenne minimum de 12 sur
20 pour rester dans le programme et on
les voyait pendant ces séances à tous
s'entraider pour que personne ne reste
sur la touche
et voir ça pouvoir partager ce moment
avec ces jeunes pour créer un lien avec
eux c'était fabuleux
et si on a pu ne serait-ce qu'elle était
d'un tout petit peu dans la poursuite de
leur objectif et pour nous cette
émission accomplie
la deuxième expérience donc j'aimerais
vous parler et également lieu lors de
mon école d'ingénieur
cette fois-ci nous avons organisé un
voyage au Kenya centré sur le rugby
le club de Massy nous a donné des
équipements que nous pourrions apporter
dans un orphelinat sur place
l'idée était de leur faire une
initiation au rugby de laisser le
matériel sur place et de potentiellement
générer de nouvelles aspirations pour ce
sport qui se développe beaucoup dans le
pays
et c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai
réellement réalisé à quel point le rugby
et le sport en général permet à des
individus des inconnus de se rencontrer
je pense qu'on a tous vécu ici il est
beaucoup plus facile de rencontrer
quelqu'un pendant une séance de sport
lorsqu'il a une activité commune il a
une espèce de magie qui se crée et qui
crée un lien à une connexion directement
entre les individus
et avec les enfants il s'est passé
exactement la même chose si au début ils
étaient très timides ils avaient peur
ils restaient très loin de nous une fois
qu'on a sorti les ballons et qu'on a
commencé à leur faire des passes
instantanément en un claquement de
doigts tout le monde s'est réuni et on a
pu profiter ensemble et ça a facilité
grandement la rencontre de l'autre
et c'est fou à quel point le langage du
sport est un langage universel ce que
nous pouvions avoir des problèmes de
communication à cause de la barrière
linguistique avec eux mais pourtant dès
que nous avions un ballon dans les mains
nous parlions tous la même langue
bon j'espère qu'à travers ce témoignage
vous avez compris et être mieux saisi
pourquoi ce que ce sport m'est aussi
cher aujourd'hui
moi je l'appelle ma pépite pourquoi ce
mot de pépite parce que pour moi il
réunit les deux éléments principaux
d'une pépite
la première c'est que c'est une des
choses les plus précieuses que j'ai dans
ma vie
et la deuxième c'est que je ne savais
pas qu'elle existait avant de la trouver
et je suis tombé dessus par hasard
et si je dois choisir une seule chose
que j'aimerais que vous reteniez de ma
présentation ce soir
c'est qu'on a tous une pépite
pour ma part elle prend la forme du
rugby mais ce n'est qu'un exemple parmi
des milliards d'autres sports
d'activités qui ont le même potentiel
donc pour vous ça sera une autre forme
mais soyez convaincu qu'elle existe
j'espère que beaucoup d'entre vous ont
déjà trouvé
mais pour ceux dont ce n'est pas encore
le cas je ne peux que vous inviter à
continuer à la chercher car vous ne
pouvez pas imaginer l'impact qu'elle
peut avoir sur votre vie
merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]